- Let's talk and
- Yeah we'll see what happens.
- See the whole point of the podcast is
the moment in life where
everything changes.
- Yes.
- Did you ever think to yourself,
when you were just a little kid,
you know what?
When I get older, I'm gonna be this
internationally renowned,
inspirational figure
that's gonna really put
a dent in the universe?
(reflective piano music)
- [Gary V] I just really
believe in my thesis.
I think everybody here under 30
is rushing to do stuff
to close insecurities
and vulnerabilities, and
it's making them do things
that they're gonna regret long term.
And I just didn't!
I just,
you know what it feels
like to be 27 years old,
and see your college friends and
them making jokes that
you work in your dad's
liquor store?
I just, was able to be in my own head and
not care what anybody else thought.
And that would be my
biggest piece of advice
because I genuinely believe all of you
are in a rush for that.
I don't think you care
about a BMW or a Rolex
or spending a lot of money on a vacation,
for any other reason because of the
psychological aspects of
how that positions you
to other people.
I really believe that, and so
I just think people,
the young man, I don't know if he's here,
who's like, I'm killing it.
I want to start teaching other people,
he's so young.
Anybody could do well at Wall
Street the last six years.
Everybody.
I definitely thought I was different
at an extremely young age.
I grew up in a world that
didn't reward outwardly the
things that I was about.
It still blows my mind
that I was 15, 16 years old
making real money in my side businesses
and every teacher I had
and every friend's parent
thought I was gonna be a loser.
Man, I know we're
we're locking in a show with
him or a session, right?
A meeting?
Jonathan, man, keep fuckin' grinding, man.
All that attention on you.
(high pitched tone)
The food is just your passion.
- [Man] Sonar, sensors?
- This is killing my
killing my vibe.
Just, I'd rather you actually hit the car!
(laughs)
At this point.
Just fuckin' hit it.
Anyway, guys, who's reading "Crushing It"?
The audio's good, I'm halfway done.
When am I finishing it, next week?
(high pitched tone continues)
Alright there's something broken now.
Yeah, blang that.
(hip hop music)
(high pitched tone starts again)
This fuckin' display.
I want all new Gunna.
This is absurd.
- [Man] I turned it off too, look.
- I don't believe you.
Look for something else.
Look at that rear button.
What's that rear button that's lit up?
That's rear, that's down below?
- Yep, yep, yep.
Right there, yep.
- Now we're freezing!
(laughs)
- Turn that back on.
Turn up the car.
- No, there's snow probably.
- [Gary V] Get outta the car and wipe the
I'm gonna fucking wipe the snow.
Let me outta here.
Oh shit, it's green.
I do have to do it,
gotta entertain these people!
I'm trying to entertain
these people, A.J.!
I gotta bounce tomorrow morning,
'cause I can't watch the
fuckin' Patriots playing a game.
(laughs)
But other than that, it's
been good, how about you?
What up, man?
- Nice to meet you.
- How are you, man?
Real pleasure.
Hey, Greg!
- [Greg] Hey how are you doing?
- [Gary V] How are you, man?
Such a pleasure, how are things?
- Cold.
- It is fucking cold.
Wanna bring some chairs over?
- Yeah.
- There's so much.
- Tre's like the next generation, right?
- So much.
- Tre's livestreaming 2K on Twitch
and I mean
- They know,
'cause they're
and there's so much
money they're leaving on
so much money, happiness.
Yeah man, it's gonna be
real interesting to watch.
It's coming.
I'm talkin' about like
I mean,
if governments can be folded by this,
leagues could be folded by this.
This is way bigger.
It may not even hit his generation,
it might be
you got anybody younger than you?
If they had like a nine year old brother,
that kid, legitimately
could live in a world where
I just think the internet
kills everything in the middle.
And so,
what happened to
bookstores and happened to
limo services
that shit can happen to the fuckin' NBA.
Right?
Nobody gives a fuck about Steph Curry.
They care about his attention.
They don't give a fuck if you can
shoot from 40 feet out.
Or score 60 a night.
They care that kids are
influenced by what you say.
And whether you're fuckin' Meek Mill
or fuckin' LeBron,
or fuckin' CNN it's all the same shit!
It's understanding the strength of
if you love Twitch, you
go all in on Twitch.
If you love fashion, you
go all in on fashion.
Because every athlete
wants to be a rapper,
every rapper wants to be an athlete,
and they all want to be entrepreneurs.
That's real.
Right?
- Entrepreneurs are the new rock stars!
- 100 percent.
- Look at,
who do kids want to be?
It used to be they wanted to be that guy.
Now they want to be
Mark Zuckerberg
- You know why?
You know why they want to be me?
'Cause they can!
You need to be born blessed out your ass
to be him or
Robin our football player,
he's a fuckin' house!
(laughs)
He's all of us in one man!
With no body fat!
Did you see him take off his shirt?
Did you see that shit?
So that's why, 'cause it's actually true.
I want to be like Mike?
Fuck that.
This sneaker, you can actually be that.
I'll give you it right now!
Go on Craigslist, take all the free shit
that they're offering on the free page
in the classifieds,
bring it home, take a picture,
put it on Facebook Marketplace,
and make $400 a week.
Yo, just sell shit!
Like in about a month, he's
not gonna think that shirt
is as good as he think it's,
you know how that works.
- Right.
- Fashion.
So instead of letting it be in your house
while you're at Duke, take
a picture and sell it!
Fuckin'
the Craigslist thing is crazy.
Literally anybody on welfare
I think could become wealthy
just by having a phone and
you could have a studio,
you go to the person's house,
everybody's got a bullshit car
carry this shit on the bus!
If you're broke, grab this,
go on the bus, sit on the bus like this
everybody's gonna look at you,
be like yeah, yeah, yeah keep laughing.
Come home,
take a picture,
and fuckin' post it on
Facebook Marketplace!
15 bucks,
somebody's like, yo, I'll take your table.
Ding dong!
Yo, hello.
Here you go, sold!
You just wait
What are you doing with
and then somebody's gonna say,
but damn.
It's gonna take 40 minutes to go there,
40 minutes to take on the bus,
five minutes to post,
seven minutes
I'm gonna be like,
well what are you doing
with your time anyway?
Everybody can win,
it's about being yourself.
The truth is the fuckin' formula.
That's the strategy.
Know what I mean?
- Yeah, I feel you.
- In fuckin',
I'm telling you right now.
That's literally $35
on Facebook Marketplace
if you just pick it up.
It's seven minutes of your time.
It's 15 minutes of your time.
♪ ("Full Clip" by Gang Starr) ♪
Turn of the music.
Turn off the music,
honestly, I think I just eliminated
for the first time
(high-pitched tone)
I just eliminated for the
first time in my career
the excuse of no money.
I think it just happened.
This is like a big day for me.
Literally for 30 years, I've had to like,
pander to that excuse.
It's over.
It's actually over.
It's called Craigslist free section.
I was about to say buy it,
go take it, for free,
'cause most people just
want you to pick it up.
'Cause it's big or what have you.
If you happen to actually have a truck,
like a bigger vehicle,
than you are really set!
My friends, Craigslist Free
to then relist it on Facebook Marketplace,
the arbitrage of the internet.
We see this in retail where
people buy things in China,
post on Amazon, things of that nature,
buy on marshalls.com, sell on Amazon,
it happens.
The much more humble version
when you've got nothing,
if you're just sitting like I need money,
all those people that were like,
yo can somebody buy me Gary V's book,
I can't afford it.
That means $17 dollars,
it's there man,
I really think a real hustler
a hundred bucks, five times a day
I think it's like $300 a week.
- [Man] That's like
full time though, right?
- Nah,
I feel like people,
I think $300 bucks a week,
if you're not even doing it full time
I think if you take your 6pm to 9pm
Monday and Tuesday, picking up shit,
and then reposting it
on Facebook Marketplace
and then meeting people on Saturday
to come to your home and grab it,
I think it's $300 a week, man.
I think it could be even bigger.
Why are we still lost?
This is it?
(laughs)
When's he going?
How?
A lot of attractive people in here!
- Wow
- A lot of
attractive people in here.
- Right here, he just walked in!
(hip hop music)
- [Man] Gary V!
- Oh you live?
(laughs)
Oh we're up to a whole lot!
Cameras everywhere.
Fucking cameras everywhere.
Alright let's go.
Oh, shit.
I go, what's going on?
They know about it and they're against it?
The O.R. team, the P.R. team.
Who's P.R.?
Hmm.
Should we meet in the parking lot?
Can you scour my Twitter and
can you look at all my
Baban, can you do that too actually,
can you look at all the tweets, replies?
So we're trying to do a meetup.
'Cause I have to be at Mall of America,
so I figured I'd be like, hey,
I can meet you there real quick.
I didn't want to disrupt it in any way.
But it seems like security
is not excited about it
or something, I don't
know the details yet.
I figured with all the
football players there
big crowds, you know?
So, we're on our way there.
It's snowing.
Trying to figure it out.
Got to move it to the IHOP.
What do you think?
- I think as soon we walk
in, we're kicked out.
- I bet you,
they know who I am,
I've interacted with the Mall of America
Twitter account.
They're gonna be, hello
sir, you're outta here!
Yeah, fuck that.
We're gonna lose.
- Just in the parking lot of IHOP.
- Snapchat, I'm moving the meetup.
I'm gonna move it to the IHOP on Killebrew
I'm just not gonna be
able to pull this off
at the Mall of America.
I just feel like they're
gonna kick me out.
Should I buy a thousand
dollars worth of pancakes
so they let us all in?
(high pitched tone)
Really?
Holy shit.
They think I'm in that bus!
(laughs)
Go straight go straight
go straight go straight.
I want to go away from
pull in right here, yeah, right here.
Yep.
Watch this.
(laughs)
You get out first, Baban.
We should be like, hey!
Yo!
- [Fan] There he is!
(crowd cheering)
- Don't slip, don't slip!
- Gary motherfuckin' dude
- What up man?
- How are you doing?
- Good brother, how are you?
- Oh my God, it's such
a pleasure to meet you.
- Nice to meet you,
I'm sorry it's so cold!
- Gary, nice to meet you.
- What up, man?
How are you?
- Don't be sorry, we live here man!
- [Gary] Yeah you guys know!
What's up, man!
- Hey nice to meet you.
- Good to see you again, man.
There's a lot of people
listening who don't know
who I am and so it's
tough to come out the gate
after you said such a nice thing
to say, yes I knew.
But I, for example,
actually let's do this backwards.
I really think it's an
extremely small fraction
of the actual way it all plays out,
right this minute.
- [Interviewer] 'kay.
- [Gary V] So I think we
sit here 27 years from now,
and it starts getting really weird.
- [Interviewer] Like really weird.
- [Gary V] Like really weird.
- [Interviewer] In terms of the reach
- [Gary] I think everybody
will know who I am.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- [Gary] And I think I'm going
to have a real positive impact.
- [Fan] Someone selling a TV for $20 bucks
immediately posted it,
found like 50 people,
sold it for $200 bucks.
- That's my guy!
The flip, baby!
- I appreciate it.
- The flip, let's go.
- Could you take a picture of us?
- Let's do it.
- Awesome.
- [Gary] I will not forget this.
- I just want to give something
you totally changed my life.
I know you get off on hearing that,
and I just, I mean that
from the bottom of my heart.
- Thank you, brother.
- One last thing that's kinda fucked up,
could you sign my shoe?
- Yes.
- I have no Crushing It for you to sign.
- No worries, brother.
- Can you sign the outside right here?
- Yeah I got you.
- Yeah, look at that!
- [Fan] Dude's signing his shoes!
- We're going inside!
Okay the update is, it's fucking cold.
And we're going inside and
I'm gonna keep the line
the way it was.
It pull from opposite directions,
most of my success comes from that,
and maybe that double life
I lived during my childhood
'cause I'm not scared of losing,
'cause I was told that I was losing.
- Right, you were gonna lose anyway!
- That's right!
- They were saying, look you're
not gonna amount to anything
anyway, so in your mind, you're thinking,
why not try?
- House money.
House money, and I didn't believe them.
It wasn't even just like,
well if I have nothing to lose,
I was like, you're wrong.
What is making you not jump all in?
Usually, not crazy results
in a short period of time,
which means you're looking for,
you're not looking for marriages,
you're looking for hookups.
That's why you haven't figured it out.
Everybody thinks
everybody is on stuck, this is a great
two themes in a row.
Everybody's stuck on the idea of it.
Guys, it's not the idea of it.
Ways
wasn't a new innovation.
Right?
Instagram wasn't a new innovation.
Spotify wasn't a new,
guys, it's like,
it's execution.
So usually people are bouncing
around their businesses,
'cause they think they'll
come up with an idea
it's gonna launch, and
fuckin' nirvana's gonna come.
You know?
It's just not!
It's fuckin' execution.
Nothing I've ever done in
my life is some new thing.
I've just done it better, harder, longer
it's just in the edges.
Elon Musk is not in this room right now.
You understand?
So you're bouncing around,
'cause you're not
getting the traction that
you're looking for.
Because you're probably
judging way too fast.
VaynerMedia sucked shit the
first two years, me and AJ
had a long debate about selling
it for a million dollars
to Buddy Media, 29 months in.
Yeah, I mean like everybody thinks like
Guys, most people are
not actual entrepreneurs.
We are, as a collective universe,
being tricked that we are.
Just keep that in mind.
(reflective piano music)